23 year old velodimir is training on a
helicopter in Western Ukraine that's
older than he is a soviet-designed mi
17.
this is a combat transfer helicopter
that we use for training rather than
combat missions it's quite a good
machine because it's light and easy to
use
many helicopters lack modern weapons or
high-tech anti-missile systems Pilots
are often forced to fly perilously low
to avoid detection or manually calculate
their targets
philodamia says that when he flies in
combat he tries not to think about the
risk
there is fear but only before the
helicopter starts to launch as soon as
the rotor starts spinning then
everything disappears and you understand
what you're doing focus on the task
complete it then there's no more fear
when in combat pilots fly up to four
sorties a day
what all these Pilots have told us is
that what the Ukrainian military really
needs is not only more helicopters but
more modern ones
we want more long-range and powerful
weapons it will save us time and allow
us to operate at a greater distance
flying newer helicopters will be easier
too the better the weapons the less we
are in danger
Britain to Sea Kings several other
countries have promised or sent some
helicopters to Kiev in the meantime as
the war on the ground grinds on
Ukraine's pilots make do with what they
have and continue to defy the odds in
the air
Western Ukraine
still ahead here on Al Jazeera ancient
culture revived we'll be looking at the
team working to recover